Watch that posture!
When it comes to first impressions, your body language goes a long way...
...in conveying confidence and competence.
Learning how to carry yourself during a job interview...
...may mean the difference between being written off and being remembered.
You will need a strong walk, a firm grip, a connection and clarity.
Step one. Walk in, make eye contact and deliver a handshake with a firm grip,...
...looking your interviewer right in the eye.
Confident body language suggests you are the perfect candidate for the job.
Step two. Sit up straight with your feet firmly on the floor.
Don't rock, drum fingers, glance around or shake your foot.
Slumping, fidgeting or apparent impatience comes off as low self-esteem, or worse, disinterest.
Step three. Connect with your interviewer.
Nod, use your hands while talking and be enthusiastic...
...without overdoing it to the point of distraction or insincerity.
Step four. Enunciate clearly, taking time to consider questions.
Convey the sincerity they can expect you to bring to the job.
Speak slowly, deliberately, with resonance and confidence.
Step five. Smile once in a while.
Be personable and feel free to ask questions,...
...taking control so that the interview becomes a relaxed conversation.
Mirror the interviewer's body language, which is known as a joining technique.
If their arms and/or legs are crossed or closed, do the same.
If they move their hands when they speak, they're considered open.
Step six. Walk out with purpose and strength.
No matter how you feel you've done, leave with your head held high.
Did you know?
From 2006 through 2008, the number of Americans...
...receiving outplacement support after a layoff increased by 50 percent.